- Oh! Oh! He wrote back!
He wrote back!
- I've been with my wife
for about ten years.
- I've been married for seven years.
- We met because we lived in the same dorm
freshman year of college.
- I've been married for
about two and a half years.
- We were set up by my best friend
who married us.
- I've never once used a
dating app in my entire life.
- Dating apps didn't
exist when I was single.
- OkCupid was a thing
when I was in college,
but it was kind of like
there was a certain type of person
who online-dated at that point.
- I don't even know if
I've ever been on a date.
- Tinder scares me.
It feels a little shallow and judgemental.
- So I'm putting on
Tinder for the first time.
- Which way do I swipe?
- The first person on my
Tinder is saucy as hell!
- Definitely not!
Griffin?
- Oh! Oh! It's a match!
It's a match!
Oh boy!
Okay, wait!
Do I send him a message?
- This is you with your mother.
- This is actually just like a video game
and it's really fun.
- Oo, gosh! I just got a match!
What the hell does that mean?
- Super like Ryan?
No! No!
- Is it weird to send
like multiple messages
to a stranger?
Like I just messaged three times in a row.
- My second photo is a photo
taken on my wedding day.
(laughs)
Hopefully no one swipes to that photo.
- He's looking for fun, friendship,
and possibly a greencard,
like that's funny!
- I don't know which one this guy is!
There are like eight
people in this profile.
- If I was on Tinder, my
bio would be just like--
just a string of eggplant emojis.
Just straightforward.
- I think that a lot of these men on here
are confused as to what
is attractive to women.
- Tinder was really fun,
but I feel like as soon
as I get a response back,
then it's going to be like
really daunting and scary.
- I feel weird game-ifying
something that could be real.
- If I was single, I would
definitely use Tinder.
- I actually think it'd be something fun
for my husband and I to play together
as like a judging people sort of thing.
- Being married fucking rules!
- It does feel like there's a bunch
of wonderful people here.
Can I just have a Tinder for friends?
I want to meet!
I want to hang out!
I'll bring my wife!